[Music]  Prince and Paris Jackson get in some  sibling bonding time and my sister is  busy with her work so we're gonna catch  up for sure Michael Jackson's oldest  kids Pelt around all weekend long first  with a motorcycle adventure Prince  shared this pic with assists captioning  it to get you a ride or die to ride into  the sunset she has a very big  gold then the pair cleaned up for their  cousin ciggies wedding he's the son of  Michael's brother Jackie siggy shared  the same shot of Prince in Paris with  the caption that this is what family  means my cousins held me up and together  for my wedding and let my wife know that  she is family siggy also posted this pic  of Prince standing with the other  groomsmen on his big day it's always  about family